I look at the glass half-full bride
right I don't need you negativity she
came into the studio pretty negative ona
back said he seized up last night in the
middle of the night woke up then
backseats up this morning back lower
back season three that's where you hold
hold my stress
you hold stress in your back and in your
hair that's probably probably probably
hair and lower back so when you dress
cuts right through the propecia I take
one of the hems I should say the
finasteride thank you yeah promo code
fighter so why are you so stressed just
this whole fro the seriously I can hold
down all the [ __ ] I got a hold down the
midst of a coronavirus that's what's
hard you tried to hold down just I'm a
nut TV show we're talking about podcasts
we're talking about touring we're
talking about all this crazy [ __ ] well
well don't sip in like ya driving me
nuts no but uh Torian TV leave me be
leave me toy TV I know I wish that was
the case for me I can ABC let me off the
hook here yeah I know we're shooting
speed [ __ ] dude uh hold up are you
saying that you make the podcast Monday
cuz your shoot I'm sorry Wednesday
that's the problem if you're all McKay
I know Joel McHale Joel McHale I'm just
so excited and I got a do this [ __ ]
and ABC's like get back in there we
gotta shoot these scenes I'm like dude
what about gauranga and they're like
shut the [ __ ] up we're gonna power
through it now is the head of ABC Dana
White Dana White if the head of ABC now
he took over ABC that makes sense I know
you're lying I'm genuine so so so I
looked at ik to today even genuinely
worried really hates me how worried I am
how I got worried ass Jackson smooth now
what were these accident smooth it's
it's 1:00 in the afternoon that is that
23 year old Tony trying to misquote oh
yeah that's my help me how worried I am
how worried are you dude
it's 1:00 p.m. yeah Monday you'll start
worrying
that's impressive that's impressive you
don't give a [ __ ] it's not that I don't
give a [ __ ] what are you gonna do dude
I'll tell you exactly what I'm doing
I'll take exact you wanna know what I do
and this you know you're gonna do I do
right i fret noblesse you've read I do
that too
I did that too I sucked my thumb thumb
take my ass i fret my butt my butt perks
and I say the people I go don't have
money for the work you're doing around
my house but I do have a hole I have a
couple holes a warm mouth well that's
why I said to the workers I said guys
good news and bad news like this the
good news that well the bad news is
don't have money daddy doesn't have
money daddy on that money the good news
is I got holes so you got holes daddy
has a warm mouth and I'm looking for you
to pork your [ __ ] and I got and I got a
very tight starfish that doesn't know
what time it is yeah but here's the
thing he's open for business he's open
for you guess what fellas he has to be
he has to because boot business is
a-boomin we're taking the walks off and
if I get a little Crone up in my up my
[ __ ] I got a little cry on my [ __ ]
and you're open 6 a.m. to 6 a.m. get
this work done keep this work on you
understand and hey did they take that
payment um we don't know yet that's
gonna happen after the podcast please
film yeah I'm going to and then I'm
gonna sell the film online and make my
money back - so you see what holy fans
calm Bryan Callen this is a time for
opportunity this is not a time dude I'm
I'm you know I don't if you were if you
want negative [ __ ] and you know the
world it's doomsday you know and they
this ain't the place to comment cuz you
can get it anywhere turn on the news
turn on any what we don't need that man
fortunes are made in crisis a lot of
times a lot of money was made a lot of
fortunes were made during the Great
Depression and and I think that this is
a time Andrew Schultz said that's very
eloquently I agree with them it's a time
it's an opportunity to get books read
you haven't read to start something you
haven't started it's not easy man it's
[ __ ] stressful you don't know if
you're gonna have money yeah the problem
is when it's like three books of it I'm
with you and I'm licking the glass
half-full - but and it hit me cuz so
many people do me a lot of people do
read a book [ __ ] I'm trying to feed
Mike it's a huge problem
what are you talking about have a book
do I have money for food no but I'm
trying to keep my [ __ ] like last row
that's I lost my job but even read a
book no but that's what I'm worried
about that's not that's 97 percent of
the world that's people we know very
dearly and very closely who don't like
I'm like you don't have any money
how are you buying food you time I like
some comics we lost Konica there are a
lot of people
that live literally that have 200 hours
in the back oh yeah well I mean the
average I think the average American is
four hundred dollars are left in the
Buddy I was six hundred or something but
either way thank you for this I think
it's four hundred this is a [ __ ]
disaster
but this is but this is this is the
world we live in this is this happens is
when do we get back to work and is the
juice worth the squeeze so what do I
mean well so here's what I'm saying
people are talking about we don't
actually a lot of the data is still very
very iffy but here's the bottom line is
that unemployment might kill more people
than the corona Bob would you say 30%
unemployment or a depression a global
depression a national depression could
kill more people than any [ __ ] virus
could I mean in terms of suicides in
terms of domestic violence in terms of
all kinds of things that happen to
people when they can't afford to live
can't afford to buy food so I think
there gets a there gets a point where we
go hey let's get back to work is there a
way we can borrow yeah what do you talk
what do you mean hey let's get back to
work you don't think everybody wants get
back to work everybody get back to what
I do you know I don't think there's yet
spread Reviva is not as if you don't
plan well the plan is to stop the virus
the plan has like that Italian
restaurant you roasted all the rest no
one gives a frank talk about these
businesses well south of so many lives
are being taken well I understand she
was trying to stop so I first of all
excuse me
no they're not being taken yet well we
know that they're not in fact I just
spoke to my buddies in the front line of
this he's a physician and he called me
up and he's my neighbor he said I can
have the kids play it with each other
cuz I'm gonna be at the phone lines that
he's in to UCLA hospital and he's
dealing with all this and I said to him
I go is it getting better or worse he
goes we just don't know right now okay
so we're still in a holding pattern we
know Italy the fact is the fact that
matter is we know China
well socials are Korean and China but we
don't know we can't trust China we can
trust Italy because most of the people
dying are very old and infirm correct
but but with with South Korea they got a
hold of this because they were really
smart about testing they have testing
boots so everybody gets tested and they
know to quarantine themselves we've been
caught with our [ __ ] pants down here
that's a one good thing that comes out
of this it will never be hopefully we'll
never be caught with our pants down in
terms of not knowing
how to deal with a pandemic testing and
all those things it's a new virus I
understand but we got to figure out a
way to get people who are not [ __ ]
positive in the workforce and and and I
I think there gets there comes a point
where you have to decide whether or not
the young people we know are gonna live
okay 98 percent success rate
yeah again all but all this whatever
you've heard whatever heard a lot of
this is bro science just to your point
we don't have any actual have injection
a lot a lot a lot of a lot of its on
though we actually have some we actually
have some pretty interesting stats on
the on the cruise ship so they were
almost all elderly and they had they
think they think less than 1% mortality
rate and those were very old people but
the less than 1% because they got the
medication right now then you get the
medication they don't know if all of
them died of corona those so here's the
other problem very few people have been
tested for it including when you know
when we have those rates of how many
people died of influenza old people a
lot of people do way more than but they
don't get tested usually so they can die
from other things so we're not sure but
usually that that is a factor when you
catch a bad flu you know we lose
something like it's a it's a crazy
number of people so we do have some some
petri dish studies some of them is one
of it one of them is the cruise ship
Italy places like that we also have
success we have some success stories
like China for example which I believe
is up and running that's the word and
and South Korea which actually never
really shut down correct me if I'm wrong
but I'll have you heard about again yeah
what would I'm spewing out something
I've heard other people talk about very
much pardon me but like you know where
the in Washington was the hotbed where
they had the really bad cases yeah up up
in Washington that old folks home they
they got that medication that
transferring talk now and buyer medicine
donate like five million dollars worth
of pills or something like that for
maybe just straight-up five million
dollar or five million pills for the
medication and the success rate with
that medication that they have to clear
by the FDA I think that's where that's
what trumps timeout the success rates
like 98 percent when they take this
matter yeah what is it like a malaria I
don't know combination Sheriff
so I just think it's very I think it's a
huge
the rest of the country which is we're
not ready for this we're not ready for a
pen no one was though yeah no one was oh
you got a you got we did this has got to
be here's the thing we spent a fuckload
of money worrying about other things
okay
and we spent a fuckload of time talking
about other threats according to Bill
Gates this is the biggest threat we face
something like this it's happened on a
smaller scale we got to be [ __ ] ready
for this so and there are ways you say
the young should go back to work I
believe you've ever idea
I believe that's that's what I think so
and I think it's up to the young and the
old to quarantine themselves if you're
an at-risk person I don't think you shut
down and destroy the entire if you have
world rely on health issues yes you
should maybe very hard and I do think
the people are going to die but I don't
think that you're going to save more
lives if we have a [ __ ] Club my only
my mom with a honey bee sound was on you
I'm on board with this plan my only
thing is I do you mind my buddy Jeff
Susskind like one most successful I know
smart dude black belt jujitsu one of my
best friends lives in Denver
more time out Corona and I'm always
positive I'm like yeah but 98% success
rate and I'm telling mother stuff and he
goes dude hold on hold on hold on I'm
like what he goes dude I've a friend you
know him in Denver he's 38 years old
he's the most in-shape person we know he
rides his bike like Lance Armstrong
every day competes in races finishes
first eats healthy than anybody you know
he got coronavirus I'm like in East 30s
yeah you look a the success rate it's
like 99 percent for that age group was
that yeah yeah so he goes right that's
what you hear right he goes he's in he's
in the hospital he's not doing well I'll
make it but I said does he have
underlying issues nothing no but that's
anecdotal so we know that actually
according to the stats that's a that's
an anecdote for the most part people who
are young are far more likely to
experience mouth symptoms and by the way
so I call it the boomer virus everybody
got mad with h1n1 and certain things
like that not even the Boomer virus but
it's it's though it's the very very old
virus so it's for people who are 81
rights the reason it's there's debris
the heavy rank right I don't want my my
parents are 80 almost I don't want them
to die of course but I'm saying
that it you can't destroy everybody's
way of life and I'm talking about
boarding up restaurants and 50% of the
restaurants and stuff like that with all
who they employ you can't do that to
people
and I don't think that flooding the
market with government stimulus with the
trillion dollars or more 1.6 trillion
dollars what does that do I'll tell you
what it does it jacks inflation when
inflation goes up you got it you got
interest rates go up this kills an
economy so we there is a point where the
reaction the cure is worse than the
disease
and I think that's what we that's the
conversation IIIi think what the
government's trying to do is stop this
at all cost before it gets more lives or
lost businesses they know you're not a
business they know the economy's gonna
eat [ __ ] but they're just trying to save
human lives so so that that the smart
thing here it seems is that we don't
want to overrun the health care system
right that's the big things because
remember if you overcome overcome them
with the coronavirus all the other cases
don't get treated as well so a lot of
people die it's not just that they die
of coronavirus if you don't have enough
hospital beds for people who are
bleeding and all the earth they die so
we know that
well again again caught with our pants
down again not really ready again
hopefully we go we take this more
seriously but no one was ready be well
that was that's true it's called a Black
Swan it's something that nobody could
have predicted but I think our our
overreaction has to be taken into
account and I think that's on the money
I like to like this lady who watches my
kiddos comes over and she's so stressed
out like what are you doing she's
watching the news my god you can't that
there's nothing positive makes much they
create such such they've been very
responsive stress and [ __ ] just dire
times and stock up on this and do this
this person's dying oh why don't you
guys tell about China right what about
South Korea right what about Germany
right what about what about what about
no money or what about the lady who is
102 years old you got Corona and beat it
yeah what about that lady yeah
what about all whatever what about all
these what about is a gas majority of
area you beat it you know what you know
why they can't do that though because
then these lock downs and try and
contain the buyers people won't take you
serious
well they create this fear so
98% of especially in the US are shutting
it down to you that's giving them a lot
of credit I would say the media for the
most part make money selling fear as
usual and I'm not just talking about the
liberal media I'm talking about [ __ ]
Fox News everything they make money
doing this and they should your local
news ABC NBC CBS
you can't watch you need that [ __ ] man
cuz you think the world's ending yeah
gonna blow your [ __ ] head off
yeah and I told I told my girls mom
who's watching chemo stressed out but
the lady who helps out my kid owes me
you guys got a stopwatch right here all
woman beats coronavirus that is so
awesome AZ of course she is she's that
go [ __ ] yourself I've seen everything
she's seen the Black Plague at one 103
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]